نبدا هذا الصباح بمشاركه العالم في 31 من
مايو من كل عام احتفاله سنوي باليوم
العالمي للاجتناعي
هذا الامر الذي يشغل الحيز الاكبر من
اهتمام الدول ومنظمه الصحه العالميه التي
اكدت في حملتها هذا العام ضروره التوعيه
بالزراعه البديله لزراعه التبؤ نحتاج الى
الغذاء وليس الطبخ هو شعار الذي اطلقته
المنظمه في سبيل استبدال زراعه الماده
التي تضر الانسان الى بدائل تفيده الجهود
الدوليه ترمي الى المساهمه في توسيع
الاراضي الزراعيه في حل هذه الازمه ازمه
الغذاء العالميه وتقديم ما يفيد المجال
تحقيق الامن الغذائي العالمي بدلا من
السبب هو ما يتبعه من اضرار المزيد دائما
مع لميس ابراهيم لميس
ارقام صادمه
تؤكد الدراسات ان زراعه الطبقه احد
الاسباب المباشره في تنامي ازمه الغذاء
العالميه 3.5 مليون هكتار من الاراضي
الزراعيه في العالم يتم زراعتها بالطبخ في
كل عام ما يؤدي لتفاقم ازمه الغذاء
العالمي 200 الف هكتار من الغابات يتم
ازالتها سنويا لاجل زراعه التبغ بما يساهم
في تدهور التربه خصوصا مع استخدام
المبيدات المكثفه تسعه من اكبر عشر مزارع
للطبخ موجوده في البلدان المنخفضه
والمتوسط دخل التي تزيد فيها المعاناه
الغذائيه اربعه بلدان من الدول التي يزرع
فيها تبغ تعاني من ازمه زراعيه وعجز في
ميزان الغذاء بسبب قله الموارد
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياضه فهد ماجد الغشيام
مدير اداره التشغيل في شركه بدائل صبحك
الله بالخير استاذ فهد
صباح النور عليكم وعلى المشاهدين الكرام
حياك الله بدائل خلينا نسال اليوم يعني
المنظمه منظمه الصحه العالميه او كذلك
منظمات الامم المتحده تدعو الى زراعه
بديله سعوديه كانت قد انتهت جد ذلك في
استبدال اشجار القات بزراعه القهوه اليوم
ما هي البدائل عن التدخين
ممتاز البدائل حقيقه التي تقدمها اليوم
شركه بدائل هي بدائل مبتكره
الهدف منها تقليل
التدخين
ومكافحه انتشار التدخين في المملكه وفي
الدول المجاوره باذن الله
طيب الحقيقه استاذ فهد يعني اسم الشركه
مثير للاهتمام وملفت والفكره من ورائها
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا الجانب الفكره من وراء
بدائل بشكل عام سواء كان في مجال التدخين
او غير
ممتاز الفكره من الشركه هي استثمار من
صندوق استمارات العامه في جوده الحياه في
المملكه مثل ما تعرفون ارقام التدخين في
ازدياد اعداد المدخنين في ازدياد والامراض
المترتبه عن ذلك ايضا في ازدياد
وبالتالي لابد الحكومه قامت في المملكه
بجهود كبيره للحجم التدخين مثل بوزاره
الصحه
وجاء تاسيس بدائل كاحد الروافد التي
ستساعد وتساهم في دعم هذه الجهود باذن
الله مثل ما ذكرت سالفا عن طريق تقديم
منتجات مبتكره جديده
تساهم وتساعد المدخنين على الاقلاع عن
التدخين هل هذه المنتجات باتت قيد التنفيذ
وتداول المستهلك حتى يستغني عن التدخين
وهذه العاده
باذن الله ستكون متوفره من اليوم
وسيتمكن المستهلكين في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من استخدامها بحول الله
لبدايه الرحله
المهمه لترك التدخين مثل شنو استاذ فهد
البدائل
البدائل عباره عن اظرف خاليه من التبغ
تستخدم عن طريق الفم ما فيها تدخين
تساعد
المدخن على الانتقال من التدخين الى مرحله
العدم التدخين باذن الله
يعني تحفيز الناس على السعي للحياه بشكل
صحي اكبر هل لديكم في الشركه يعني ما هو
ابعد فقط ابعد من موضوع التدخين بدائل
عفوا عادات صحيه سيئه نحن نمارسها ولكم
لكم
لديكم لها الحل
سؤال جميل لانه فعلا اسم الشركه هو بدائل
وباذن الله الهدف في الاستراتيجي العام هو
توفير بدائل صحيه مثل ما تفضلتي
البدائل التدخين هي نقطه بدايه اتمنى منها
ان شاء الله بالانطلاق الى بدائل اخرى
احنا عندنا قسم للبحث التطوير في خبرات
محليه واجنبيه ستقوم بالبحث في كافه
المجالات الممكن
الحصول فيها على بدائل صحيه افضل
جميل الاستاذ فهد ماجد شيان مدير اداره
التشغيل في شركه بدائل شكرا جزيلا لك اعلم
حجم المهمه الكبيره اللي تواجهونها خاصه
في انه شركات التبغ كذلك تسعى الى تسويق
منتجاتها وتضخ دعايات واموال كبيره مهمتكم
في تحسين جوده الحياه ليس فقط في التدخين
ايضا ان شاء الله تكون كبيره وناجحه شكرا
جزيلا لك
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات